hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreigner again and
today we're back at the dev stream
recaps there wasn't much news today
because they're still prepping for e3 so
I do apologize for that but we do have a
few things to note so this is probably
another quick video so let's get started
so first up there's a new event playlist
available or you could play the
beachhead only map on Dominion so if you
do want to check that map out and it
seemed interesting definitely go play
that event mode another reminder is that
the event bundles are now up so if you
have any specific character you want to
get the bundles for definitely do that
now and also a random comment is that
you can pull out the sword and the sword
the stone emo I forgot to mention this
last week but yes you can pull that out
if you do have the emo just so you know
because I got a lot of people asking me
in stream if you can or cannot so that's
just the answer for that the new content
of the week is battle outfits these
outfits are battle outfits yes so there
really aren't that great but they are
not faction specific so you can get any
of those outfits for any character in
the game which is pretty nice if you do
want to grab that and also they showed a
trailer again that was released
yesterday if you missed it this is the
part that was the most important I'll
play it in the background a lot of
people are thinking it's a Persian or
Chinese warrior I'm hoping we get a
pirate I've seen a lot of people say
it's a pirate but that's just only
because I have a bias and I do like
pirates that put a lot of sea of Thieves
but either way it's very interesting and
so most likely be talked about at e3 but
if you want to see a little bit more
about that a little bit more of a
discussion and more in the comment
section of what people think click the I
on the top right you can go to my recent
video or it'll be at the end of this
video if you just want to see it better
or it won't want to look at the comment
section if you want to get a little
discussion going with everybody else but
yeah it's gonna be end of the video
today guys once again like I said sorry
that there wasn't really much news today
I try to make these videos as
entertaining as possible and as well as
most informative as possible but like I
said there wasn't much to talk about
today since most of the news is gonna be
saved for e3 so probably next week
you'll probably see the same thing cuz
this week is currently May 31st next
week they're gonna have another dev
stream and then immediately after that
they're probably going to go to e3 so
we're on June 11th I believe is the e3
day conference for Ubisoft so probably
try not to expect much either next week
but once again I'll recap it all for you
guys just in case you we need it but as
always like the V if you do enjoy it
subscribe if you're new I cover the
leaks the informational site of fallen
or balanced
just patch notes event updates all that
good type of stuff my two most recent
videos would be on screen if you guys
want to check that out that guy's hope
you agree wrister day any parts in the
video peace out